mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
the 1947 stanford competitive
examination included a version of this
problem
i bought 72 identical items
each item had the same cost and the cost
was a whole number of dollars
the total cost was a five digit number
you don't know the first or last digit
but the middle three digits are six
seven and nine
how much did each item cost
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
i will illustrate the answer using two
different methods
let's get started with a brute force
calculation
the total number of items i bought is
equal to 72.
if we multiply that by the cost per item
we will get the total cost of all items
we can then vary the item cost and that
will affect the total cost
we're looking for a five digit number
where the middle three digits are equal
to six seven and nine eventually we will
come across the possibility of thirty
six thousand seven hundred and ninety
two
therefore the item cost is equal to five
hundred and eleven dollars
while this method is useful with today's
computational methods
we should remember that in 1947 people
didn't have such powerful computers like
we do today
the other issue with this method is it
doesn't tell us anything about the
structure of this problem
so now let's solve the problem using
logic to understand it in another way
the key insight is that 72 is equal to 8
times 9.
this means the total cost must be
divisible by both eight and nine
so let's recall some divisibility rules
we'll get started with the divisibility
rule for eight a number is divisible by
eight if its last three digits are
we have a five digit number and we'll
focus on the last three digits
recall that 800 is equal to eight times
one hundred
if we subtract eight from both sides we
get 792 is equal to 8 times 99
if we subtract 8 again from both sides
we get 784 is equal to 8 times 98.
seeing that two of the digits must be
equal to 7 and 9 the only possibility
that works is 792
therefore the last digit must be equal
to 2.
let's now go back to our five digit
number and suppose the first digit is
equal to a
let's recall the divisibility rule for
nine
a number is divisible by nine if the sum
of its digits is divisible by nine we
will therefore take the sum of these
five digits
then seven plus nine plus two is equal
to 18.
notice that 18 is a multiple of 9 so we
can eliminate that
we then want a plus 6 to be a multiple
of 9.
the only way this will happen is if a
plus 6 is equal to 9 because a is a
digit between one and nine
this means a is equal to three and
that's the first digit
so our five digit number will be thirty
six thousand seven hundred and ninety
two
we can then divide by 72 to get the cost
per item and that'll be 511.
for completeness let's put in the dollar
symbols
therefore our answer is 511 dollars
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems one video at a time
[Music]
you